struggling with social anxiety what if I
told you it's not a flaw it's your
brain's brilliant design to keep you
safe that's right social anxiety is your
ancient survival Instinct working
perfectly here's the Turning Point
social skills are like muscles the more
you use them the stronger they get start
small eye contact a follow-up question
or sharing a story each interaction
builds your confidence and here's a
secret listening is your superpower when
you listen 70% of the time and speak
only 30% people feel truly understood
their brain even rewards them for it
curiosity that's your cheat code ask
questions that uncover fascinating
stories watch how people light up when
you show genuine interest but wait
there's more every person you meet is
three versions of themselves who they
think they are who others think they are
and who they truly are understanding
this makes you more patient empathetic
and connected ready to transform social
life watch the full video and unlock the
secrets to becoming effortlessly social
it's easier than you think